hello YouTube just lowers in my friends
this is crunch in here today we are
going to learn about system which is
against the Carrick and defense and
which is known as a Spassky system the
name has been given from the famous
chess player Boris Spassky who actually
invented this system and it also known
sometimes as a Spassky gambit as well
okay so let me quickly go through what
is it so white played efore and the
general response of character is start
with C 6 and after d4 d5 here variation
goes with FIFA which is the advanced
variation of the caracal and here there
are few moves for the black but I will
go through only the most general
response of the black which is either
Bishop f5 or the c5 which I have
highlighted here by the arrow so the
main line goes like this
so I place bishop fi and here I
recommend you play Knightly too the idea
is very simple 9 wants to go to g3 where
it can attack the bishop and gain some
kind of tempo where the main line runs
like this so black plays a six white
plays Knight g3 Bishop goes back to g6
h4 and here there are two choices for
black if you
I know about the system he most likely
to play h5 so here there is a very
simple line which give you a plus
position for a white and it runs like
this so white plays Bishop e2 and
targeting that Jew CH v square and it's
not only black has a weak made weakness
attach file also white has a weakness as
h4 and black can exploit that as well by
playing Bishop to e7 and now there are
few captures happen so for example
sample line can goes like this show
Bishop takes now black recapture with
the bishop and then white will capture
with the night and here black can play
this g6 and when night comes to f4 which
is a good square rather than the g3 here
again there are few captures rook
captures as four captures and Bishop
takes and if you analyze this position
with any chess engine or any software it
will give you at least one point plus
the simple reason is you can see this
ePHI pawn which give you give you a very
good space in the blue cape so anyways
this is a side line and this is a this
line you can analyze further if you are
planning to play this line in the
tournament and it's a very comfortable
game from here onwards for the white ok
that's not our part of discussion let's
deviate to the main line which is a
Spassky variation and Spassky Venetian
start when black plays at six and this
will be the more frequent response of
the black
here first we'll grab a space so we'll
attack that Bishop and once the bishop
goes bad now we'll put this Bishop d3
and main line goes like the Bishop
captures Bishop and now a very very
amazing move by the Spassky which is C
cross V 3 and at the first side looks
like very suicidal because now you can
see this your d4 point becomes very weak
and it does not have any support from
from backside and that's a weak side let
me talk about the plus side of this move
now the plus side is first of all if you
notice the black position it's very
solid but let's say if it wants black
wants to open the game up somewhere down
the line he has to play this c5 moon he
has to play the C if I move now well in
that case moves slightly what will
happen is white is going to capture that
pawn and then this pawn will go further
and that way the pawn center of the
white will remain impact and that means
black cannot reshuffle it or disturb it
with the pole that's one good side the
other good sign is white has very very
good an effective plan of attack on the
black King side and let me reveal
Spassky plan which we are going to see
in the rest of my video and the plan
goes like this so rewrite is most likely
to go castle
the Queen most likely goes to the g4
square and now you see the good side of
this two pawns
Aoife n h5
they that give you a great comfort of
the Queen and that means Queen cannot be
had as once it comes to the g4 and then
our f1 will roll to either f5 or f6
depending on the scenario and this is
very very effective and very very
attacking plan and black has to play
very very accurate or careful moves
otherwise it can be go down very very
quickly and we'll see some of my own
games and how good for Hal get from this
line and that's why I'm recommending
this line to you
okay that's the overall plan of the
white now let's see how the black can
disturb this plans now here black has
three good moves and the first if first
one is let me go to the main line of the
Spassky variation or the Spassky gambit
which occurs when black plays Queen b6
it's very logical Queen comes to the
very National square of b6 and not only
there it tagged the weakest spot on the
white cam which is the d4 right now and
here the gambit occurs where we have to
completely gambit this one which is this
V to pawn and white plays Bishop e3 now
if you put your queen on b6
there is no point it's going to stay
there and not capturing that b2 1 so the
main idea is to capture the pawn the
necklace black is one point up here and
it doesn't seems like I might have any
compensation right now but let's see how
the white can exploit this so why trade
Knight d2 variables you need to protect
the rook
and now here there are two lines to
erase he lines let me reveal the first
line where black is play this move which
should be for its very initial because
leg is upon up so black wants to get rid
of some of the pieces so he wants to
quickly switch to the end game where
it's solid pawn structure matters much
more why it has a very good reply first
of all White Castle over here and after
Bishop takes Knight there comes the
intermezzo which is route to be one now
we need to stay in protag with the
bishop so Queen forcefully has to
capture there now
White will recapture and now you can see
the b7 pawn is hanging right now and if
the rook has been allowed to move to the
seventh friend it can be very dangerous
for the black so it's very important for
black right now to stop that so in one
of my game my opponent play b6 and here
have a lovely move which is Bishop to
Poe and why does it stopping some what
Kings had activity of the black and here
there are two main moves for the black
the first is Knight to d7 and in in
either of the cases our more will be
very much similar so first of all we're
going to play
Queen to g4 will allow to attack on g7
and the downside of the black is black
cannot play g6 because our H Phi is
there so that's why black has to
forcefully play this move look to at
seven
and now there is amazing over here I
wonder if you can spot it I give you a
few seconds try to find out amazing move
over here okay
the amazing move is Knight to f5 and
first side it looks like you're giving
up a piece for nothing but it has a
deeper idea so there are two lines exist
over here fortunately I had two games in
in one of my game
my opponent accept this sacrifice so he
took with the across a fire and then I
recaptured the Queen now you can see
that Queen is attacking the rook so who
has to go back and now comes amazing boo
e six so it's okay you are piece down
but you can see the black king is in
center so it's very logical that white
is try to open up the game and hear my
opponent played Knight f6 he thought
that it will be too dangerous to capture
that pawn so anyways I took the f7 he
recapture and now comes Luke II rook F
evil and now you can see those squares a
seven and a six they are so weak and
although I'm a piece now it's a very
very attacking position for me and ma as
a result my opponent godowns very very
quickly over here
my opponent played this move C fast so
it's somehow stopping that Bishop but
after Queen e6 King f8 can you spot
another amazing
okay and that is BAM Bishop takes and no
place for hiding of the black ink so
black has to forcefully capture this
Bishop and then you can see it yes it is
route to be seven and bye-bye King it
solo and see how amazing attacking
position you getting from this kind of
system and you will see more and more as
I'll go through the video okay so that
is one line when black capture the
knight in another game one of my
opponent played this move so he played
see fie counter attacking my bishop okay
so first of all I give this check so I
say my Knightly so I played Knight to d6
+ and my opponent responded King to e7
and then I capture that pawn he
recaptured and then I move my bishop to
the c3 now of course it's not a very
accurate game you can say because the
five minute splits game and hear my
opponent fleed feel very very greasy
he probably feel intimated because the
way I was attacking so he he thought he
should be attacking as well and he
played this move
he played d4 but this is a disaster zone
because now comes a very good move can
you spot it yep it's Queen to f3 which
is has the two melts it's not only
attacking the rook in the corner but it
also attacking this one Epps Evan so
black has to forcefully go this move
AFET and now I give you a few second try
to find a winning continuation for the
white okay and the Vinny condition
starts with this more look to b7 see
it's how amazing you are
self-sacrificing more and more material
but you are gaining a black King which
is which is the whole point and here
there are a few things first let me tell
you what does not happen in the game
let's for example if your opponent to
player play this B cross C 3 then there
is a fridge so shows this mating 4 so
you can identify biome it's very simple
rook sacrifice again and then after King
takes this is made so that doesn't
happen in the game my opponent what was
hydrated so around 2000 plus so he
identify that and he played this good
move which is queen defy his idea was
very simple
he is materially ahead so if we can
exchange the Queen then it can be very
good fun
of course it's if the King Queen has
been exchanged it is good for the black
but the situation is so was for the
black that is it hardly can escape and I
played this move Knight a5 check and he
has to go back so he play Queen King to
d8 and now after a few calculation of
you thinking I figured out that this is
a winning position for me and I capture
the Queen and here we capture and then I
give this jack
then when the King goes to the eh I
played this more rook to c7 now I'm
planning my planning is very simple I
want to go over here and make blacking
and probably he is in trying trouble or
what I don't know he played this
disaster movie played Knight to e7 he
thought he can stop that rogue but that
fall another way it's a meeting - yeah
it seems even so you give this check and
King comes to the only spare yet and now
double discover checkmate so see another
very very attacking and entertaining
game for me now let's have a look to the
another option which is at this point
black and play another move which is
Knight to e7
instead of Knight to d7 well here again
our plan will be very simple as you all
know now so we play Queen to g4
attacking the juicy g7 and this time
Black has some options so black need not
to play at 7 black can play this route
to g8 and in this game I decided to cap
the King in the center so I take the
knight a key capture and then here goes
my plan so I played f4 ok my up and
responded with the developing Knight to
d7
anyways I carried on the attack with the
f5 see how easy it is it's it's very
easy to remember and it's very very
aggressive if your opponent play at this
position across F Phi then there is a
very nice continuation which is which
goes like this so first of all Queen
check and after King goes to e 8 now you
can recapture with the night and you
threatening a checkmate so black has a
I think so only reply which is AB six
and now you can play this a six and a
sample line can goes like this so King
goes King run away from there well 20g
three rook to DA trying to attack the
pawn took constitute even and if fi
trying to run some of the pawns on the
Queen side then comes a disaster there
is seven check and after King goes over
here 96 this is actually happen in one
of my game sorry I forgot that yeah so
that was a what another amazing position
for me as an attacking position for me
okay another game I opponent doesn't
capture that and he played this move
Queen d2 now idea is very simple he
wants to block the check of my queen
with his one queen and if it's allowed
it can capture some of my pawns now here
there are few moves but the most
accurate move over here looked to f4
which is cutting off the communication
between queen and that square G Phi
so my opponent goes like this so my
opponent grab the pawn so it's now
attacking my rope and I paid this first
of all this check and when the King was
there I played rook have fun now see you
are almost how many three pawns are down
and not only that black has this Queen
side majority and see over here and all
he needs to do is to and this pawns on
the board and make a Queen's but he does
not have time for that and you will see
again this time my opponent will run
down very very quickly now here he
played this move
c5 it's very logical you want to
undermine that undermine my pawn chain
but now comes the tactic so f cross C 6
f cross e 6 and now I played Queen g-41
and decide to run away so he played King
d8 and I grabbed the prong he played
rook to e8 attacking my queen I grabbed
another pawn so I played a queen cross
d5 and now I can see this rook is
hanging right now so he has to play this
move rook 2 CH and now I played into f2
but I don't know at this point it was a
right more wrong move but I thought I
want to play rook to f7
and if I play that black has a chance of
grabbing this pawn and simplifying my
queen so I don't want that that's why I
played this wonderful move which is king
to s2 and hear my opponent play Queen
III and I played but of risk we drew cap
7 and the maid has been threatened so he
has to support denied with a rope and
now can you identify a winning sequence
from here onwards I'll give you a few
seconds ok sequence goes like this so
Queen Jack look has to come back and now
come BAM good dicks and it's every
attackers dream position where you just
sacrifice like this and you threaten
your opponents all kind of tricks and I
was very delightful when I played this
one and no option Bly has to capture and
it's very simple Queen goes to defy Shaq
if King goes to e7 then recap 7 will
leads to checkmate so my opponent play
king c7 but to his horror he ran he
realized that she lost position because
after Luke f7 it's at least made in
truth
again a very entertaining game okay so
that was all about Bishop b4 line you
get this kind of fun they'll either move
over here wear black and immediately
retrieve the Queen so it can play Queen
to b6 value here I recommend you should
play castle and after night seven you
play f4 now this is a very solid system
by the black what he is planning is is
stopping your fi by putting his all
night to their file so now no more f5
pushes there but anyways you see how you
can force this issue so here we'll
capture the night and after black
recapture the first of all play route b1
attacking the Queen and when once the
Queen goes to c7 now you play g4 and at
first sight it looks like you are
opening up your king this looks like
your king is new right now but the thing
is black does not have any attack going
on it's all species you can see this
rook or Knight Bishop and this roof all
are on sitting on the background so it's
very very safe for the white and why it
is all set because all pieces are very
very active and they all are set to
attack and that's why g4 makes a big
sense now I haven't achieved this
position in the any of my game so I I
recommend you should analyze by own with
your chance offense but I give
guarantee this is a very good position
for the white Honda mover insight to d7
now it has an idea of tricking you
so for example it has idea of Queen to
b6 and if by foolishness white plays
Knight to c3 then Queen b6 comes with a
very good effect so that's why it's a
kind of waiting move
so what white needs to do over here he
has to play this move and this is my own
line
so it's up here you are going to play or
not this is a very very aggressive line
again so we play queen g4 and after c5
this happens in one of my game I played
castle my opponent grabbed the pawn and
then I continued with my own lon so I
played a for coming up and I responded
with Knight isse Evan and after some
thinking I pushed on my opponent took
the pile Aoife and then I place my twin
tweto now for computer it's very very
easy to defend this position probably it
will give you minus one or two points
for the other white but as a human you
will not be feeling comfortable and I
could show you one of my simple game so
it could runs like this so my opponent
played f6 I played Bishop f4 he played
Knight to c6 and then I recapture the
pole then he plays Bishop d6 and then I
play Knight f5
and after he castle I took the light he
recaptured and then I played 92 he
played hooky 8 I play Knight f3 he
capture that I capture he capture and I
pre Quincy 4 and here see it happens
when you are attacking your opponent
mistakes and hear my opponent play Queen
d7 and this is a big mistake because now
comes boom Knight cross g7 and now you
can see the my queen is unleash the rook
so black cannot capture the knight and
the pollution is roughly balanced I
prefer white because it has a more
attack okay so that is about Knight to
d7 now there's a one another move major
C file let's see how we can win this so
you can capture this they capture we
play before and now instead of losing a
time one of my opponent played Bishop
before I block with the knight c3 and
then up knight c6 I play queen g4 again
this Queen D form coming up often and
often in the smile so queen g4 and if my
opponent has to play a bass he moves
such as Bishop to affair then my
development will be very tremendous so
in this game up and I decide to play
King to f8 and then I canceled he took
my knight i recaptured the pawn and then
he played Knight to e7 and can you
guessed it yep at the same plan nothing
to think beyond on that and
we player 4 we are planning a fire and
just gave my opponent play Queen to d7
it somehow he thought that he can stop
that but not I played a fire here you
capture are you captured with the nine
he wrecking after he captured denied
here I found a one good Intermezzo which
I give this check my opponent goes King
yet and then I recapture the rope and
position for Mac excuse me because it's
only thing that his doing is defending
and you cannot win in chess by only
defending unless and until the open make
me get us ok let's see how the game
continues so my opponent play rube g8 of
course he has to defend at g7 and then I
played this amazing a6 again again and
again so we are opening the center
because the king is sitting in the
center and we are not allowing him to
run away and here there are two lines
too bad lines I should say one of my
opponent play F cross E six and I play
the screen check after King goes over
here I pay rook F 7 and he play Queen
Queen to e8 and then after this move he
resigned because he found to his horror
that there is no escape from here C is a
disgusting position for black
and if here if he's going to capture the
Queen then so far I played Queen f3
my opponent play rook to d8 supporting
that defy and now comes a very good
movie this King to f2 planning his group
to even and what's egg is doing about it
and he played a g6 and after up 6 he
just move over the Queen but after the
rook even checked the only thing he has
to do is resign and another very very
entertaining game and see this kind of
fun you are getting in Spassky variation
of this basket system there any kind of
weighted player whether it's a bureau
2000 over 2000 player whether you win a
loss you get a very very attacking chess
and there is a more kind of enjoyable
experience okay before we leave let me
go through a sideline which is after
ePHI black and play this more sefa this
is known as a bot filling system now
against bots winning system again I for
you I have found our very aggressive
line so the line goes like this so you
first of all capture this and now there
are two moves for the black over here
one is Knight to c6 and another is a six
let's deal with them by tongue so first
moves Knight to c6 here you should play
Bishop to b5
and if your opponent play is six then
you play before so you are giving a
support to the c5 and if let's say black
many quiet moves like ninety seven or
Bishop d7 all okay since P pawn can be
supported very easily by C 3 and a 3 and
what might will remain a one point up
over here so the only a guess you line
can be goes like this
so if black wants to regain the pole he
has to play this book Queen h4 and the
idea is very simple not only is
attacking that fall but he is Iying for
that he fo check and this happens in one
of my game and against this I have a
very very amazing system which I am
going to reveal you right now I've let
c3 and he played this check idea is very
simple with check he wants to get g2 and
here you play this would move Knight e 2
and after Queen we gain that pawn I give
you few second try to find amazing
Mordor which actually give you the
opponent Queen so in this case you will
trap the black Queen can you find our
missing over here
okay the moments light to g3 and now the
idea is very simple you want to play
Bishop f4 f1 and checkmate to the black
queen so this happens when one of who
again my opponent realize that so he
played your Queens to h3 and again I
played this move Bishop to g4 and you
can see now again I'm stopping all the
squares where keep Queen can escape so
he tried to escape again by h5 but
finally I played f3 and I stopped that
clear as well then I finally won the
cream and the game so that is a1 the
entertaining line which can be goes if
you opponent become greedy let's deal
with another motor which is if your
opponent going to play a six then
there is a very good line which where
you can hold on to that pole and or
maybe at least if you do not then you
have a you have a better position than
black and that line goes like this a
bishop goes to III and after that again
there are two moves if you are not going
to play knight c6 then you can again
play the Bishop b5 and again as yoi my
arrow I have shown the plan that you can
reinforce that c5 pawn so the most
theoretical line as the book suggested
that goes like this
so black plays Knight to e7 and idea is
very very simple
that after we play c3 he wants to play
Knight to f5 so it's attacking the
bishop is attacking the pawn and the
whole idea of c3 is reveal now so we are
going to play Bishop to d4 and we are
solidly protecting everything and here
if you are going to play Queen c7 which
has a merit of attacking this model then
we have a very good line goes language
so we play a Bishop to d3 and after some
simplification like Bishop cross c5 we
should cross defy queen cross FIFA we
capture the night and when the black
recapture we play Knight of three and
after knight c6 Castle castle and 92 the
plan is very very simple we want to go
to from here and to here and you can see
our knight will be posted and it will be
a very very monster night because it
cannot be harassed by any fonts
the white will be have a very very good
game from here onwards I hope you enjoy
all the fire fireworks which I have
explained today
and please please at least give a short
in at least online or some friendly
tournaments and you will roll as the
good potential of this line please feel
free to comment on my video and I will
post a new video soon bye